-Jada, I know that you're
an incredible actress,
and I wanted to really put
your acting skills to the test
by trying something new.
We're going to take some
of these crazy spam e-mails
that are totally real
and perform them
as dramatic monologues.
It's time for
"Tonight Show" Spamologues.
-♪♪ Spam, spam, spam,
spamologues ♪♪
-Now, you should know
that every spam e-mail
we're about to perform
is 100% real.
These are real spam e-mails.
Jada, you're the guest,
so please go first.
She's getting into character.
Wow.
♪♪♪♪
-Hello. How are you?
This is a powerful bank
in China.
How are you?
A powerful benefactor
has left you with money.
How are you?
Click here for more information.
Moneynow.com.com.
Best regards, Nancy.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! That's how to do it.
Setting the bar high.
That is how you do it
right there.
I don't know
if I could go with this one.
Wow. That's how to do it
right there.
All right. Here we go.
Get ready to see my acting.
Oh, boy. [ Clears throat ]
♪♪♪♪
Hi.
I would love to meet for drinks
and hear all about you.
You can tell me everything.
Then I will tell you everything.
Everything.
We can meet at a hotel.
Send the address,
and I will go there.
The day does not matter.
I will make the time to be there
when you are there.
Once we have exchanged all the
information about each other,
we can see where things go.
I will see you at the hotel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-I can't even keep
a straight face.
All right. I can't even
keep a straight face.
All right, Jada, you're next.
Let's see what you got.
-Oh, no.
♪♪♪♪
Solomon.
You're not going to believe
what I have to tell you.
Ready for it?
One word.
Hummus.
[ Laughter ]
It's going places.
I was in the grocery store
the other day,
and there were about
30 different varieties.
Also you can cut up carrots
and dip them.
Have you ever done that,
Solomon?
[ Laughter ]
Want to see all the different
kinds of humms there are?
Then just click here.
And again that word is...
hummus.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And the Emmy goes to...
Fantastic. All right.
We have one more.
You want to do this one
together?
-Okay, great.
-Let's split this one up.
All right. You start off.
Your card's over there.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughs ]
-Hi, darling.
Why did you stop being my friend
on Snapchart?
I'm hurt.
But, hey, I liked your pictures
that you send to me.
-I like the one
with the shirt on.
Then the one with the shirt off.
And then the one with
the shirt back on again.
Want to see pictures of me
with the shirt?
I think I know the answer.
-Add me as a friend on Snapchat
by clicking here,
and you will see
all the pictures I send you.
-Yours now and forever, Desmond.
-That's all the time we have
for "Tonight Show" Spamologues.
Jada Pinkett Smith!
That's how it's done!
Show 'em how it's done!